mit diesem plan könnte man tatsächlich
eines der größten probleme unserer zeit
lösen wenn er denn klappt die rede ist
vom trinkwassermangel in vielen regionen
dieser erde
ein unternehmer aus den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten hat jetzt einen
kühnen plan eisberge aus der antarktis
sollen tausende von kilometern
transportiert werden um den wasserarmen
regionen als frisches trinkwasser
aufbereitet zu werden
j wie genau das funktionieren soll und
wie erfolgsversprechend das projekt
tatsächlich ist jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
neue science videos abonniert den kanal
gerne herzlich willkommen auch wenn die
erde zu rund 70 prozent vom wasser
bedeckt ist nur ein prozent der
wasservorräte weltweit ist direkt als
trinkwasser verfügbar und das ist ein
riesiges problem
laut weltgesundheitsorganisation who und
unicef haben mehr als 800 millionen
menschen weltweit keinen zugang zu
sauberem wasser 2,3 milliarden das sind
fast dreimal so viele menschen haben
nicht die möglichkeit sanitäre anlagen
wie toiletten zu benutzen
wassermangel betrifft derzeit vor allem
noch die ärmsten auf dieser welt doch
schon bald werden auch die wasservorräte
bedroht sein wo sie derzeit noch im
überfluss vorhanden sind und klar ist
ohne wasser gibt es kein leben keine
industrie und keine landwirtschaft mit
diesem versorgungsproblem hat sich auch
der arabische unternehmer abdullah als
chemie beschäftigt er hat eine idee
aufgegriffen die schon seit den 70er
jahren immer wieder mal diskutiert wird
sein plan einen eisberg von der
antarktis bis nach dubai zu befördern
um das eis dort als trinkwasser nutzen
zu können dazu als wenn wir mit diesem
projekt erfolgreich sind könnte es eines
der größten probleme der welt lösen
eine pilotstudie ist für november
geplant satellitenbilder sollen
analysiert werden um im südlichen ozean
nach einem geeigneten eisberg zu suchen
dieser könnte dann mithilfe von ketten
und netzen und einer flotte anboten nach
australien oder südafrika geschleppt
werden
das gewicht der eisberge auf die es als
chemie abgesehen hat wird auf etwa 100
millionen tonnen geschätzt
es handelt sich also um richtige mammut
berge viel zu groß
als dass sie von schiffen allein gezogen
werden könnten so soll laut plan nach
günstigen meeresströmungen ausschau
gehalten werden um die reise zu
beschleunigen das arabische unternehmen
schätzt dass eisberge solcher dimension
mit einer geschwindigkeit von etwa
zweieinhalb kilometern pro stunde bewegt
werden könnten also sehr sehr langsam
eine reise in die vereinigten arabischen
emirate könnte so bis zu elf monate
dauern am ziel angekommen sollte eisberg
dann nach und nach in kleinere teile
zerkleinert werden tankschiffe könnten
das eis zum ufer bringen hier müsste das
wasser dann gereinigt werden und könnte
somit an wasser gesellschaften oder die
jeweilige regierung verkauft werden doch
es gibt noch einige herausforderungen
die bewältigt werden müssen eine große
menge des eisberges würde wohl während
des transportes schmelzen oder sogar
auseinanderfallen dazu der
gletscherexperte nick holschuh von der
universität washington
der transport von eis über diese
entfernung wird eine große
herausforderung sein man muss nicht nur
mit verlusten durch direktes schmelzen
rechnen auch das mechanische aufbrechen
des eisbergs muss verhindert werden dass
warme meereswasser wärmere luft und
belastung durch das abschleppen werden
die stabilität des eisbergs beeinflussen
als selbst zeigt sich davon
unbeeindruckt er geht davon aus dass nur
30 prozent des eisberges auf der reise
von der antarktis in die arabischen
emirate schmelzen werden alle kosten und
mühen seines wert wenn man damit den
trinkwasserbedarf zahlreicher menschen
decken könnte konkret geht er von 100
millionen bis 200 millionen kubikmeter
süßwasser aus die in einem eisberg
eingeschlossen sind diese könnten
ausreichen um eine million menschen für
fünf jahre mit trinkwasser zu versorgen
so als chemie zudem sei auch nicht mit
negativen folgen für die umwelt zu
rechnen schließlich würden lediglich
diejenigen eisbergen wegtransportiert
die bereits vom eisschild der antarktis
abgebrochen sein die kosten des
projektes werden auf 60 millionen dollar
geschätzt das wort von privaten
investoren übernommen werden lautes
arabische unternehmers könnte der plan
bereits im kommenden frühjahr in die tat
umgesetzt werden
langfristig will als dann zahlreiche
eisberge in region liefern die unter
wassermangel
dazu der unternehmer die ganze welt
braucht wasser aber zuerst würden wir
länder wie indien südafrika und saudi
arabien betrachten sagt er seine idee
hat jetzt bereits nachahmer gefunden ein
team aus südafrika norwegen und
frankreich plant ebenfalls eine solche
mission konkret soll hier kapstadt mit
einem eisberg aus der antarktis
beliefert werden dazu der
südafrikanische schifffahrts experte
nicholas lohnt die leute denken immer
noch die idee sei verrückt aber in
letzter zeit wird diese lösung immer
öfter diskutiert und es setzt langsam
ein umdenken ein kapstadt hat in diesem
jahr extrem unter wassermenge mangel
leiden müssen
das waschen von autos das blumen gießen
oder das pool befüllen wurde von der
regierung strengstens verboten würde
seinen eisberg projekt teurer
entsalzungsanlagen überflüssig machen
und somit keine mehrkosten für kapstadt
bedeuten das einzige was noch fehle sei
das gros der stadt denn investoren für
das projekt seien bereits gefunden so
und jetzt könnt ihr die sieger bei den
community award 2018 des wissenschafts
video welches fast vorwärts 1
mitbestimmen ich war ja als jurymitglied
dabei und kann nur sagen hammer videos
hier steht wie es geht und hier drunter
ist die playlist mit allen finalisten
abgestimmt wird einfach mit einem like
oder einem kommentar ich drücke allen
teilnehmerinnen die daumen bis dann
bleibt dran